it's been a crazy week in america let's
find out what happened
president biden and russian president
vladimir putin met for a summit in
geneva this week
and there was only one thing on their
agenda
he he smells like cheetos
smells like he looks florida governor
ron desantis signed a bill this week
that would make public schools hold a
mandatory minute of silence for student
prayer
said students in florida dear god please
get me out of florida
to celebrate independence day president
biden will reportedly host a cookout
on the white house south lawn i'm going
to skip it
said black people about the potato salad
production of the nbc competition show
ultimate slip and slide was reportedly
paused this month
after 40 crew members developed
explosive diarrhea that's
really crappy their ratings are going to
be in the toilet
stopping production was the right thing
to doo-doo
no ifs ands or mud buts about it
at least they had a good runs you should
have seen the look in their feces
that crew is going to need a pep toe
talk
the truth squirts well you know what
they say no bubble guts no glory
did you like doing that no
fun fact about tarik he doesn't want to
talk about poop with you
but if you put it on a cue card he's to
say it
i will i will like that bit and
anchorman he'll just read it well just
read it he doesn't care good morning san
diego
[Laughter]
caravan company airstream recently
unveiled a new camper van that costs
two hundred and fourteen thousand
dollars it includes a heated floor
a clothesline and a vanity mirror it's
perfect for when you want to go camping
but
you don't want to go camping according
to a recent study
57 percent of americans said that they
have wanted to slap
a politician while the other 43 percent
have tried they tried it
they tried i remember how when we were
like oh nothing was going to happen to
them
and then one by one they started going
to jail yeah is it
is it the way is that that way
it really worked it was the best it was
one of the best
times of my life whenever i started
dragging those
every time someone gets arrested that
song pops into my head
yeah and it's like a little prayer for
me i love it
it's not nice to want bad things for
people
but sometimes it's good
delta airlines reportedly diverted three
flights from los angeles this month
due to unruly passengers they've updated
their motto from keep climbing to
keep playing and i will turn this plane
around
[Music]
and finally dc entertainment reportedly
told the creators of the adult animated
series harley quinn
to cut an oral sex scene between batman
and catwoman
because quote it's hard to sell a toy if
batman
is also going down on someone well that
depends on what kind of toys you're
selling
justice is going down justice
is going down meanwhile
um who is it meanwhile dj khaled was
like
oh right i gotta get all these batman
um uh hey don't google it you don't need
to know
um and that was the monologue hey amber
yes derek
oh i'm still worried about the people
who caught on that show who caught
diarrhea
me too it's no laughing fecal matter
i said it's no laughing fecal matter t i
can't i'm sorry i'm broken today
he hates it but he loves it a little bit
a little bit in other news early voting
for the new york city mayoral race is
underway to see who will replace current
mayor bill de blasio but
this year the process is a little
different for the first time ever the
city is using
ranked choice voting it's a great system
that should lead to a more equitable
voting process but
some voters are still confused about how
it works well
have no fear because we here at the
amber ruffin show have come up with a
simple demonstration to show you how
it's done
okay so wally here is going to be our
voter say hi wally hi
he's going to do the ranking and me
tarek
corrine and jenny are going to be the
candidates
wait i thought we were going to rank
pizza toppings
we were going to do that but this feels
more realistic i don't want to rank you
guys you're my friends
wally it's just a demonstration there is
no wrong answer nobody's taking this
seriously
uh i am so am i well
i guess i am now too as am i okay wally
rank us no i don't wanna do it but
everyone's gonna be mad at me
can i just put you all as number one
that's not how this works
if it was up to me wally that would be
exactly how it works
corrine don't be a kiss ass wally pick
can i do it anonymously i mean you can
but you're the only voter so we're still
going to know
what you chose dang it rank us rank us
rank us oh
[Music]
wait wait can i write someone in
actually
i don't know can he do that i'm looking
it up
yeah he can do that oh well in that case
i know the perfect person
i choose bill de blasio oh
wally okay
apparently there was a wrong answer well
hopefully this goes better in the real
world
now speaking of the real world as
pandemic restrictions lift more and more
americans are venturing out of their
homes and
returning to their office jobs but some
black people have noted that
after spending the pandemic with their
families going back to work at their
predominantly white office jobs has a
certain
unforeseen difficulty let me explain
i get back to work it's been a year
you know that i'm feeling all right
excited to see
my work friends even though they're all
white
i asked jill how her weekend was she
said oh i got sunburned
she asked me how my weekend was i said
you know a [ __ ] got turned
i could see it in her eyes she was so
surprised
she's got no idea what i said
i forgot how to code switch i wish i
could take it back i forgot how to cold
switch
what i said was just too black i forgot
how to cold switch
i think i scared her a little bit i
forgot how to code switch
and all white workplace just say [ __ ] it
ain't [ __ ]
[Music]
dude my white work friends are pretty
cool
but kevin's always trying to get smacked
talking about what's popping baby girl
even though i say don't talk like that
but it's been a year
i see him say it's been a minute what do
we do
he replies i've been straight up cold
chillin boo
i can see it in his eyes he was so
surprised
now he thinks he can talk to me any old
kind of way
i forgot how to code switch i wish i
could take it back i forgot how to code
switch
what i said was just too bad i forgot
how to code switch
some people ain't got no class i forgot
how to code switch
i'm gonna end up beating his ass i'mma
beat his ass
[Music]
been in this pandemic for too damn long
hanging out with my family so my
blackness
is strong i can't remember
how i ever used to talk like i was on
an episode of friends ow
this whole song was just a joke if you
work at a place where you feel like you
have to code switch
just tell them don't go around and catch
these hands
i mean why wouldn't you they won't know
what it means anyway
i forgot how to code switch i wish i
could take it back i forgot how to code
switch
what i said was just in black i forgot
how to code switch
i think i scared him a little bit i
forgot how to code switch
and all white workplace just ain't [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Music]
i have my own youtube channel now yay be
sure to subscribe for a lot of show
clips and a lot of digital exclusives
and a lot of this
you